wedeln heiraten in der schweiz mit
glykol versicherungen groupe mutuel seit
20 jahren für sie da von vier paaren
handeln dieser geschichten von
glücklichen die sich dazu entschieden
haben ihre liebe zu besiegeln
auch vor gott von menschen die diesem
zeichen der liebe mehr beachtung
schenken als allen irdischen bedenken
und die sich deshalb nicht davon
abbringen lassen koste es was es wolle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
obwohl weder manuela egger noch
christian hilfiger fleißiger kirchgänger
sind wollen sie ihren bund fürs leben in
der kirche besiegeln
und ich warte mit ihren pop und ich
denke es ist genug wenn du oben 55
minuten vor 11 da bist
10 weil wenn wenn wenn ich sehe dass du
bekommst mit dem auto
wenn ich dieses autos dich sehe dann
kann ich leute die noch draußen hinein
rufen
und er hilft wie viele türsteher letzte
woche übten manuela und christian für
den hochzeitstanz christian reich ließ
sich in der dominikanischen republik von
bieren wie nieder del carmen verwöhnen
treten petkovic wurde am polterabend
genauso wie seine braut aldiana
novakovic von halb nackten tatsachen
überrascht und landwirt rudi bärtschi
versuchte seiner braut andrea buchecker
das melken beizubringen wie kommt hier
beiden hinein in die kirche du hast
schon gesehen dein körper bringt dich
hinein
ob ihr könnt nicht nebeneinander es ist
einfach zu schmal
ihr müsst nicht darf ich zeig dir ihr
müsst wie versetzt
nur noch wenige wochen dauert es bis die
breiten gehörlosen manuela an christian
hier in merligen am thunersee heiraten
werden
hier wird christian also am großen tag
stehen und kaum erwarten können dass
seine braut kommt
noch nicht
falsche moment kann ich denke er hat
sich an der hand und gibt einfach deine
haben und dann geht dir beide hinaus
setzt euch
es gibt keine kein gesetz aber keine
vorschrift wie was ist euch angenehm
das war mir jetzt klar dass christian
sich verstecken will
[Musik]
ein
in puerto plata hat christian reich im
hohen alter sein glück gefunden
die ferien in der dominikanischen
republik wurden für den senior vor sechs
jahren zu einem unverhofften liebes
abenteuer zum größten und schönsten wir
heute betreut
und so hat nicht merkt halt damit der
damen und die honorige und dann bin ich
doch sehr hoch und dann haben wir jeden
tag schaffen und nachher bin ich immer
laufen bankrisiken warten bis sie fertig
und das war auch für mich überraschend
viele männer nicht einladen wollen aber
ich habe immer nein gesagt weil ich auf
eine ganz besondere person gewartet habe
und nun also wollen wir in wien nieder-
und christian für immer zusammenbleiben
aldiana novakovic uns retten petkovic
haben vor wenigen tagen von ihrem
junggesellendasein abschied genommen
heute wirken sie sich im beisein ihrer
eltern und geschwister standesamtlich
trauen lassen
für die traditionsbewussten serben mit
schweizer pass ein aufregender tag
auch wenn sie treten seine anspannung
kaum anmerken lässt
[Applaus]
das spiel in die hand
die wissenschaft
nicht nur rohstoffe
ganze arbeit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also schon naja ich hoffe dass auf der
unterschrift gibt also eher glücklich
machen eigentlich machen dem himmel sehr
glücklich machen wenn er nach jedem
schritt und sie gibt es schon oft ich
war nicht so einfach wenn du mich nach
jedem steht mir sondern oder schmuck
schuhe
er weiß dass auch wenn ich glücklich bin
und wenn es mir dort gut immer wenn ich
[Gelächter]
eigentlich sehr aggressiv immer
glücklich bin denke ich muss sowieso die
aktie da schon ob ich mit ihnen sonst
mal cool
auch der hochzeitstermin von andrea
buchecker und uli bärtschi rückt näher
endlich haben sie zeit ein geeignetes
lokal für den hochzeits abgrund zu
suchen
der toggenburger landwirt und die
mitarbeiterin der hochschule st gallen
rechnen damit dass das halbe dorf
vorbeischauen wird über eine supermacht
im und ums regierung aber die menschen
beschäftigen
welches bild firma ch was zum sorgerecht
aber dabei geht es vom planungsbüro
zusammen mit 200 bis 250 mehr oder
weniger schön ist dass die bekannt die
zimmerkollege ja kollege von mir aus ins
kollegen schuhe ehemaliger
arbeitskollege aktuelle arbeitskollege
familien einfach bekannt
400 karten verschickt und wenn man jetzt
am rechner das buch hatte zwei liegt
eigentlich finanziell ist da viel
erzählt und nach ostafrika wir mit euch
und er muss schon mitte bis nach
berechnen aber und das einmalig ist auch
mazda beim größten hat so viele noch
kennt und alles drum und klar
naja da passt aldiana uns reden haben
sich zur zivilen vermählung für eine
noble adresse am zugersee entschieden
[Musik]
die männer
ich nehme dich so wie du bist
[Gelächter]
vontobel
konnte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
züge und liebe gesteht stadtkreis raum
begrüßen
und es sollte mich seht die hälfte kam
ich mit ihnen reduzieren
ganz offiziell möchte sie hier petkovic
in schieflage sekunde was sie gehen
gemeinsam fortsetzen möchte
petkovic ich rechne man die
verzögerungen großen applaus
[Applaus]
die warschauer sich die vor ort
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass es eine hochzeit in weiß sein würde
stand für andrea buchecker immer außer
frage
und dass sie auch vor gott ja zueinander
sagen wollen steht ebenfalls schon lange
fest und so treffen sich andrea und uli
heute in der kirche in die gassen mit
dem fahrer dem sie christ und andreas
schwester silvia zur probe der abläufe
sein dass wir mir genannt kommunizieren
könne jederzeit alles damit machen bis
der titel
dann würden wir uns stark und bahnhöfen
wie schön ist und genau so ist es
bestehe so geschlossen
dass sie wie möglich gehen lassen
während der traurig ja wenigstens einmal
im leben bewusst mehrere faktoren oder
stand
tschuldigung mir stelle treten pardon
und du und im verständnis der vernunft
zu blüte und den vorderen mit 3000
spielen und der machen und den letzten
schritt zu mehr führen
nach ns bekenntnis zum land und das
massaker der leiche wird seine sie und
das meer ist das versprechen genau die
richtige
für den vierfach verheirateten und
wieder geschiedenen christian reich ist
der gang aufs standesamt eigentlich
nichts einzigartiges mehr
außergewöhnlich ist nur dass er seine
bmw nieder bereits zum zweiten mal
hierher führt das hat einen grund das
letzte mal vor einem jahr war er von
seiner ex frau in der schweiz noch nicht
rechtskräftig geschieden gebot durch
runter vom bürgertum ihr gebot muss
begradigen und das formal haben
[Musik]
bisher wurde die verbindung mit bi
anwender nicht anerkannt jetzt ist die
scheidung über die bühne und christian
wie die in puerto plata
sicherheitshalber noch einmal alle
papiere vorlegen
ich meine heimat 100 prozentig meter
breit und die andere die ich es die
dominikanische detoniert kita gerecht
wurde und deutlich schweizer versteht
überhaupt nehmen
es existiert nur die ehe mit
das hier
[Musik]
auf diesen tag haben manuela egger und
christian hilfiger sehnlichst gewartet
heute werden sie auf dem standesamt in
zofingen endlich zu mann und frau
[Gelächter]
eltern großeltern und geschwister der
beiden sind da und auch die engsten
freunde für das brautpaar trauzeugen und
gäste ich begrüße euch ganz herzlich zu
zivil traum und ihr seid heute hier und
sagt bewusst ja und erklärt euch bereit
den partner so zu akzeptieren wie er ist
haben sie noch fragen
[Gelächter]
dann gehen wir zum eigentlichen traum
sagt über zum christian hilfe
ich richte sie die fragliche wollen sie
mit manuela maria egger die ehe eingehen
so beantworten sie bitte die frage mit
ja ich will
manuela maria eck ich richte auch an sie
die frage maria rechte haben sie die
frage wollen sie mit christian hilfe die
ehe eingehen so beantworten sie bitte
ebenfalls die frage mit ja nicht will
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
1000 beide diese frage bejaht hat
bild.de offiziell ausgeschlossen
mit den kristall
[Musik]
zwischen dem 1
schöner könnte er nicht sein der tag an
dem treten seine aldiana zum altar
führen wird treten schwager alexander
ist seit gestern zu besuch
während aldiana bei der mutter
übernachtet hatte gegen übelkeit motor
show mitmachen
das gericht sah zur selben zeit hat
aldiana schon ihren ersten termin
zusammen mit mutter und schwester sitzt
sie in bettingen beim kaffee
boy waterman der schminke ich bin
überhaupt
ich bin ich okay das ist bitter dass
durch essen und trinke ich bin nämlich
mega angespannt und das lange wender
über die dächer und kriegt also dass ich
sehr gute besetzung sagte das ist ein
kreislauf kollaps so sich das geht so
machen
weg zum zu positioniert habe ich schon
dieser millimeter hin dritte
zur feier des tages wollen bmw nieder
und christian ganz nach oben auf den
isabel der tolles es ist der höchste
berg rund um puerto plata
dass sie endlich richtig verheiratet
sind macht christian reich fürs erste
glücklich doch noch immer verweigert das
amt für migration in zürich seiner frau
die einreise in die schweiz in der
schweiz gibt es zweimal so hoch wie hier
und dann sieht man die ganze schweiz ich
möchte wieder zeigen
die schweizer gehen schon morgen da
bliebe aber genauso gern wird geredet
wird zeigen möchte mit dem die schweiz
und die zeigen wie schön das ziel das
spezifische leute die berge der strafe
sie hat auch guten ruf jetzt wo man so
lange sind das ja mal teilt mit mehr
mitglied an sich sehe die warum das
derlei überlegungen und sorgen müssen
sich andrea und pullis
selbstverständlich keine machen
sie genießen die wenigen stunden an
denen beide zeit finden um etwas für die
hochzeit zu tun
dies mache eine späte hochzuschalten
hahne stelle
und wie beim hp nutzer unnötigen wir 18
950 mit meinem leben einfach denkt sie
die schublade was sagen spezielles teil
mehreren er selber gemacht und halle
verlegen wo früher auch puzzle stellen
müsse wenn es nach andrea ginge würden
sie die eine oder andere stunde mehr
miteinander verbringen
doch uli ist mit dem hof mit der jagd
und anderen hobbys ein viel
beschäftigter mann
und auch sie selber arbeitet noch
vollzeit aber nichts denn jedes mal du
chocolat vorlegen werden rückten es
machen will da wo sie auch macht sie
eigentlich natürlich hatten wir schon
mal frei hat mich ja darauf denn ich
nicht deren schaffen
also nichts in diese richtung kämpfen
dass auch nicht nach dem elften und
teilnahme einfach mal zaubern
gibt es auch ob das mit dem modell euro
oder 50 bilder der region schon morgen
am rb6 wenn man überhaupt mit dem status
des baustoff montag dafür interessiert
ob ich das schon zweimal aber in der
regelmäßig macht es einfach
mit dem chrysler europa verbessern und
uns machen die betriebe
man hängt ist das gar nicht vorstellen
und gar keine persisches ganze nannte
die traurig sie aber wieder etwas auf
knapp sehr schön ich hätte meinen können
dass die habs zurückgehalten
[Musik]
märchen absolut so richtig braucht zeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit
in der kleinen wohnung von alt janas
mutter sladjana geht es schon am
vormittag hoch her
ja
[Musik]
immer mehr verwandte treffen hier ein
[Applaus]
auch die angehörigen des bräutigams sind
im anmarsch
doch dürfen dieser noch nicht in die
wohnung die serbische hochzeits
tradition schreibt vor dass redens
bruder zuerst bei aldiana schwester um
die braut falschen muss
wichtig ist nicht apple gelten letzteres
könne zu behüten des videos sehen die
familie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
erst jetzt darf der schwager die braut
abholen
[Musik]
zur selben zeit in haan treten und
schwager alexander machen sich auf den
weg
der bräutigam wer als erster vor der
kirche in schwamendingen sein um die
gäste zu empfangen
wir tun ja
so
bienvenido schmückt mit einer freundin
ihr haus in puerto plata christian und
sie haben beschlossen zusammen mit
freunden ein hochzeitsfest zu feiern
es ist ein ganz wichtiger anlass für
mich deshalb bin ich ein wenig nervös
es ist wichtig weil ich den mann heirate
die ich liebe wer schon vier mal
verheiratet war lässt sich nicht aus der
ruhe bringen
doch heute braucht christian reich etwas
medizin
ja ich muss sich pro tag wunderbar aber
ich hab ihn unter kontrolle
das trifft ebenso wie für verdacht von
104 wenig und dann aber mal wieder hören
ich weiß dann noch nicht was alles
passierte die damen dem ich sein
überraschendes
was läuft ich muss einfach an häufig
dann dauert es los
[Musik]
nur noch 20 minuten fahrt trennen
aldiana von treten
[Musik]
diese ist bereits in der
serbisch-orthodoxen kirche um mit dem
fahrer und den trauzeugen
die details zu besprechen also ich hoffe
es nicht aber wenn ich mir wird
passieren
[Gelächter]
mega schönes warten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nächste woche ist es soweit auch manuela
und christian sind bereit für den großen
tag
willi und andrea schauen voraus und
planen ihre berufliche zukunft
aldiana und treten feiern traumhochzeit
und strahlend vor dem altar um die wette
und auch hier nieder und christian
können endlich feiern himmel voller
geigen heute in einer woche
[Musik]
ja ich will heiraten in der schweiz
präsentiert von amag
[Musik]